voici hélène nougaro
bonsoir vous connaissiez richard
hélène nougaro voilà un plaisir de
richard seff 2 to lose jésus godrèche et
guy a lepage qui présente tout le monde
en parle au québec
voilà avec beaucoup de bombes succès
alors pardon
quand je disais le titre de l'émission
c'est comment remet un plan bien hélène
bonsoir donc c'est la veuve de claude
nougaro décédé en mars dernier et vous
venez ici ce soir pour nous présenter
son album posthume la note bleue qui
sort sur le fameux label blue note
alors avant d'écouter quelques morceaux
du nouvel album refaire un petit
flashback didier de jazz et la java sont
full hd via tombe dans l'oubli
bon
entre jazz et la java date tombait dans
juge une maison jules en mai chaque fois
que l'on y fait la piste de fès du
support pour un baiser pour une gifle à
une petite fille en pleurs dans le vide
en plus c'est moi qui courent après et
moi qui courent après
rami mais qu'est ce que je devais faire
sur l'écran noir de mes nuits blanches
où je me fais
de cinéma une fois deux fois dix fois
vingt fois je recommence la séquence et
c6
ma fille
que se passe-t-il je n'y comprends rien
y avait une ville et y'a plus rien je me
souviens que je marche je marcherai dans
ce nouveau rôle au milieu de la crosse
ou un joint du soleil de mai s'était
plaint de couleuvres de mouvement ou et
le bruit
marie christine
mieux encore que dans la chambre rouge
thème dans la cuisine rien n'est plus
beau que les mains d'une femme dans la
farine
amstrong je ne suis pas noir je suis
blanc de peau possessive
ses singles
jean ta chanson colle à la peau
au nom paillis
beauté
tant de cailloux
ensemble
violence bouillonne jusqu'à violette
quatre boules de cuir tourner dans la
lumière
qu'est-ce de pierre
la pluie fait des claquettes sur le
trottoir à minuit parfois je la tenir
chaque lot dit tu verras tu verras tout
recommencera
tu verras tu es
l'amour c'est frais pour saturer
je
sommes-nous là haut
énorme
merci il n'y a pas grand chose à acheter
je dois dire que c'est fabuleux que
c'est extraordinaire moi j'ai pris du
plaisir extraordinaire en écoutant ses
chansons j'ai appris à écrire en
écoutant ses paroles c'est magnifique ça
fait très plaisir d'écouter ça moi j'en
connaissais aucune et c'est très joli
voilà alors maintenant on va écouter
quelques quelques morceaux donc du
nouveau cd qui s'appelle la note bleue
qui sort sur le fameux label blue note
alors évidemment j'imagine que tout ne
barreaux était très heureux quand ça lui
a été proposé de rejoindre le label de
thelonious monk de miles davis ou de
john coltrane non ah oui très très fier
c'est le directeur du label qui lui a
proposé un soir deux ont été au bataclan
pour aller voir un chanteur année alors
eelv et d'une famille de chanteurs
lyriques et de pianiste classique mais
très jeune il avait été marqué par glenn
miller par luis amstrong donc le jazz
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui a fait
connaître le jazz grâce à ses chansons
il l'a popularisé du tir d'une façon oui
en mettant des classiques de jazz
ouais une chance alors on trouve sur ce
disque sur ce nouveau disque disque
posthume donc on trouve un morceau de
d'herbie hancock qui s'appelle
cantaloupe island sur lequel il a il a
écrit les paroles qui était sur you get
free tu sais et puis une reprise en duo
de dansez sur moi avec david linx qui
est un vocaliste belge on va écouter ces
deux chansons didier
sur moi quand c'est sûr
c'est sur moi
oui
holy 3d sur les touches
six mois
et
il
voilà que nos gars ont généré album
s'appelle la note bleue bien ça aussi
journée
michaud
dans les choux
m
oh
d'une vie
voilà comme nougaro la note bleue alors
hélène
sortir sortir ce disque quelques mois
après sa mort c'est dû être une décision
délicate à prendre j'imagine non oui
tout à fait on a attendu quatre cinq
mois avant de reprendre le travail sur
l'album mais bon tu tenais tellement
justement ce qu'est ce qu'il ya un cd
sur ce label
alors ça doit vous faire bizarre d'être
à sa place ici pour être sûrs et là la
promo de l'album non dans la mesure où
j'ai un a décidé de le sortir ma jeune
j'ai accepté d'en parler
vous avez raison ça sans vous serez
aujourd'hui commencer il faut venir à la
télé pour en parler c'est comme ça tout
le monde en parle
tu me rends pas alors vous avez commencé
à travailler sur cet album avant sa
maladie un est en fait une fois qu'il
est tombé malade cela aidait à celle là
aider à vivre l'art l'a aidé à vivre un
peu comme ça a été le cas pendant sa vie
tout à fait novice a toujours été le cas
toute façon il était où il était ma
femme pas malade n'a fait des prêts si
c'est vraiment l'art et la beauté qui
l'ont qui ont aidé à vivre tout le temps
alors ce qui est terrible c'est que
l'album a été enregistré en fait
beaucoup de chansons pendant sa maladie
certains dansant son traitement contre
le cancer entre une amélioration et une
rechute
il a fait ses voix dans le studio divan
casseurs qui a réalisé l'album
à la maison aussi un petit peu on a
utilisé ses voiles et les voix fait
nougaro n'a jamais fléchi ce j'ai trouvé
ça extraordinaire serait son dernier
album d'une qualité d'écriture d'une
qualité vocale mais parfaite était quand
même alors que des fois bon avec la jeu
c'est vrai que ça suis un peu quand on
sait qu'il ya des gens qui enregistre en
studio qui se font re reliques c'est
pour avoir la voix un peu plus juste par
des logiciels jetons que c'est bien
d'entendre un vrai chanteur aussi alors
weeds est même arrivé de filmer des
séances d'enregistrement elle et lui
projeté parce qu'ils pouvaient pas ils
pouvaient pas sortir de son lit oui là
c'était tout à la fin oui j'allais au
studio et je me ramenait des images des
musiciens puisqu'il n'a pas pu en fait
enregistré en même temps que les
musiciens
ouais en tous les cas tous les musiciens
à commencer par yvan cassar qui est le
réalisateur de l'album on dit que vous
avez été exemplaire pendant cette
période et même je sais aussi ont été
exemplaires
voilà je suis très content du travail
alors claude a dit en parlant de vous
jusqu'à présent j'avais rencontré les
femmes de ma vie avec elle j'ai enfin
rencontré la femme de ma mort il savait
qu'il allait passer le restant de ses
jours avec vous oui j'ai peut-être le
côté de 20 des artistes en même temps
quand il disait ça j'étais moyennement
quand vous l'avez rencontré la réunion
j'ai rencontre à l'île de la réunion et
un mars 84 vous lui avez fait un massage
en fait c'est ça tout à fait et il a
découvert que vous étiez de toulouse il
a su que j'étais de toulouse avant que
je lui fasse le massage et ça a été
l'amour tout de suite
ah non non
on est là bien entendu déjà mais
j'espère oui oui il a eu moins de mal au
dos il m'a invité à son spectacle qui
après en fait il est reparti à l'île
maurice où il m'a appelé chevalier le
rejoindre pas prêt à repartir en france
et là je croyais que je le reverrai plus
et puis il a téléphoné puis je rentrais
à paris c'est la durée comme un damné 20
en mars par alain calmât refusant fait
des massages
et
on
voilà écoutez sachez une chose ce que
nous sommes nombreux à penser à lui à le
regretter et l'aisne
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire merci